blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an entire
non-fiction book in just 15 minutes you
can try it for free and get 25 off a
subscription by going to blinkist.com
pakman you know we really had this virus
on the ropes for a little while there
but it has come back really strongly it
has fought its way back
mostly through the unvaccinated through
the unmasked and we now have listen to
this
three times the average daily cases of
one year ago
and close to twice the daily deaths
of one year ago we're going to go
through the numbers here
and this is building on yesterday's
segment about scientists aren't sure
about the future of this pandemic when
the end is going to be later today joe
biden is going to be addressing the
nation and announcing a bunch of new
initiatives including a vaccination
requirement for every single federal
worker
that is going to be met with some
resistance for sure and we are going to
look at the numbers which are also
making it very difficult to guess about
the end of the pandemic so as reported
by
a whole bunch of different news outlets
daily us coveted cases up more than 300
percent from labor day last year daily
coronavirus cases are four times higher
than they were following labor day
weekend it really seems closer to three
now that the numbers have kind of shaken
out the number of daily deaths twice as
high it's almost twice as high about 70
percent higher
based on data from johns hopkins
university um so let's look at the
actual numbers here cases per day in the
united states
are now
300 percent higher
three times higher we could say
it might actually be even worse we're
still getting data from labor day
weekend and some states are now
reporting really slowly
in terms of deaths deaths are now 70
percent higher per day
than they were a year ago and again like
with cases actually even more so
we are still getting data from the last
10 days in terms of death some states
like florida now reporting deaths on a
huge delay to always make their most
recent numbers look better i explained
that mechanism to you last week
in terms of vaccination those numbers
are not looking so good we are really
stagnant on vaccination we are still now
in september of 2021
just the hair over
53
53.2 fully vaccinated in the united
states and when you look at other
countries if you look at at least one
dose
the us is at 63 percent
we are way way way behind so many
countries including the united arab
emirates portugal qatar
singapore spain
chile ireland canada belgium france the
uk italy bahrain the netherlands
cambodia all of these countries with
more first doses than the united states
and that is particularly depressing
when you consider that we had
essentially a full supply of vaccines
meaning if you want a vaccine you go and
get one we had a full supply much
earlier than just about every single one
of those other countries now for those
saying you know david sir cases don't
matter if people aren't getting sick if
people aren't getting hospitalized well
i already told you deaths are up 70
percent but hospitalizations are also
way up compared to a year ago
hospitalizations are about 300 percent
higher
around 100 000 we only had about 30 000
people hospitalized with covid a year
ago so what are the indicators in our
favor if there are any
one is that relative to cases deaths
aren't as high and what i mean by that
is
deaths when we had this level of cases
previously deaths were higher cases are
up 300 percent but deaths are only up 70
that means each case is less likely to
lead to death
because
half the country is now vaccinated but
of course too many people are not
and then maybe you know we aren't sure
yet
the cases are leveling off
the hospitalizations are leveling off
and we can hope that we're going to
start to see a decline there but at this
point the additional complexity is how
much of that leveling off is because of
the reporting delays in general and
because of labor day weekend
we just don't know yet so the situation
could be dramatically better than it is
i will be live streaming later today if
you you know it'll probably be an hour
after the show publishes today
but joe biden will announce a
six-pronged
new strategy for fighting the virus
it will reportedly include from what's
been reported by cnn's caitlyn collins
so far it will include
a full vaccine mandate for all federal
workers that's a lot of agencies across
the country
the reaction to that is going to be oh
this is tyranny and of course it's not
uh but the situation is not looking good
and we must
for be i feel morally uh required to
follow up about ivermectin so let's talk
about that next all right this is a
really important debunk
ivermectin has become all the rage as a
possible treatment for covid among some
americans
except
there aren't actually any blind
randomized controlled trials in humans
with a placebo group that prove
ivermectin is good for covet and humans
recently iver mekhtin got a big
publicity boost
because joe rogan took it along with
multiple other medications when he got
covered about a week and a half ago and
then in a recent segment on his show
with comedian tom segura
rogan cited something that tons of
people are citing he said listen japan
said let's use it japan is super
conservative on medications on elements
of medical and yet japan said use
ivermectin for covid
except they actually didn't this is a
huge red flag debunk that we have to do
so let's start with what joe rogan said
on his program and then go from there
it's uh
it's supposed to have uh what is the
exact
thing it's supposed to do there's
there's something that i highlighted
um
this and this is obviously i'm not a
doctor it says ivormectin was found to
be a blocker
of viral
uh replica replicase
l i r-e-p-l-i-c a s a protease and i
don't know what this word is
human t m p
r s s two i don't know but what they
didn't highlight is that i got better
yeah you got better equipment they try
to make it seem as if like
i'm doing some wacky [ __ ] that's
completely ineffective right cnn was
saying that i'm a distributor of
misinformation also that was the other
thing that happened
the um
in tokyo in japan which is apparently
uh they're very conservative about the
medication that they they use and the
medications that they uh endorse but the
tokyo medical association chairman held
a live press conference recommending
ivermectin to all doctors for all kovid
patients okay so there's a lot there a
lot of it we already looked at last week
uh let's focus on the japan thing uh the
the claim is there was this conference
press conference in japan and at the
press conference they said doctors
should use ivermectin and this is being
endlessly repeated it's being endlessly
posted the same article keeps getting
posted
and um the truth is that that video
is from february it's being posted now
as if this is a new development based on
studies of ivermectin it's not okay the
video has been floating around of a
chairperson in the japanese medical
association saying we recommend doctors
in japan use ivermectin to treat covid19
it's being posted now late august early
september as if it was just filmed and
is based on recent data it was filmed in
february it's not new the video is from
before there was really any
investigation of ivermectin for covet
19. it is now seven months later
japan has not approved of ivermectin to
be used to treat covet 19 and in fact
after the february statement that people
have been posting
japan's health ministries covid19
treatment guidelines were revised in
july
and they put ivermectin on a list
of drugs whose efficacy and safety
have not been established that's july
so the guidelines refer to reports that
the drug does not improve mortality for
covet it does not shorten
hospitalization for covid it does not
accelerate reducing viral loads in
patients with mild symptoms so first of
all the fda
the who and other organizations they
have opinions about ivermectin which you
could look at so already saying we're
going to ignore all of these opinions
and just look at what japan said
that's already strange like if you're
going to choose to ignore all of it and
say i'm only going to look at what japan
is doing you're already cherry-picking
but even if you say i'm going to only
look at japan the most recent statement
from japan is this doesn't work
ivermectin doesn't work so it
do when people post that
do not be swayed by it now one other
thing
in the segment
rogan says
i took ivermectin and i got better
this is the epitome of specious reason
reasoning i would love to be back on
joe's program and to talk about this
you have a condition which most people
recover from right like remember the
death rate overall of covid
it depends on how many people never get
tested but we believe that that the
death rate is somewhere between 0.8 and
1.5 percent roughly um in terms of the
infection fatality rate it includes the
fact that some people never get tested
most people recover from covid
regardless of what medications they take
when you take ivermectin
and azithromycin
and monoclonal antibodies
and prednisone steroids and vitamin
drips there is no possible way you can
attribute one recovery
to one of the things that you took
especially when most people recover
without taking anything it's just not an
empirical statement it's an anecdotal
statement now believe me i get emails
from people saying david why are you
against ivermect why aren't you open to
ivermectin the second we have a blind
placebo-controlled randomized controlled
trial of ivermectin that says it works i
will be right there supporting it i said
the same thing about hydroxychloroquine
and lots of other things we had the
combination of two hiv drugs that were
being looked at all these things a
couple of these
became politicized and popular
mostly among the right
i don't have i'm completely agnostic
about all of these things give me the
double-blind placebo-controlled trials
that say they work for kovid and i will
be right there saying let's go ahead and
do this we do not have that evidence
right now for ivermectin people pointing
to japan are focusing on something said
in february when japan updated their
recommendations in july
it has to stop it has to stop let me
know your thoughts you can find me on
twitter at deepakman
what if you could read 10 books in just
one sitting that's exactly what one of
my favorite apps lets you do it's called
blinkist and what they do is take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
they condense them down into text or
audio that you can consume in 15 minutes
blinkist makes sure that you're getting
all of the important core insights from
each book so it's perfect for exploring
a book you otherwise wouldn't have time
for if there's a full book you're
thinking about buying you can use
blinkist to get a sample first just
think how much you can enrich yourself
by being able to soak up an entire
non-fiction book in just 15 minutes i
recently read a brief history of time of
course by the great stephen hawking this
is a book that i have been aware of for
so long and other things got in the way
and it was fantastic to check it out on
blinkist blinkist has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different non-fiction categories and a
subscription is only about eight bucks a
month and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get 25
off a subscription when you go to
blinkist.com
david pakman i've put the link right
underneath this video
okay let me start with a follow-up about
a story from yesterday yesterday i
showed you the video of this coughing
anti-mask woman in a grocery store in
nebraska
we did not yet have that much
information about her yesterday now we
know much more about her and she has
been fired her name is janine hoskovec
this is an arizona woman
who
used to work for the software company
sap
she has been fired she was in a video
that has gone
giga viral i would call it coughing on a
mother and daughter who were shopping at
a super saver grocery store in lincoln
nebraska she's done folks let's review
the video first just so we're all on the
same page this is from yesterday and it
is horrifying
that's a
confusing excuse me
i'm coming through
vile
vile
he's popping
[Music]
because i don't need to have one on i'm
not sick and neither are you okay but
you are people how does she know you
don't know who's tripping
it's my allergies you don't know
enough right
oh you got yeah and so
two years ago before anybody started
talking about coven you were okay with
that though going out not knowing you
were sick right
you don't always worry about my health
i don't yeah janine can you deploy those
new updates to the code please
i have my allergies and she got all
freaked out cause i'm popular
no she's kind of how do you know you
don't know and she just said i don't
know anything about her health i don't
know you don't know anything about my
health i absolutely i maybe i have them
it's funny she
30 seconds prior she says we don't need
masks because i'm not sick and neither
are you and then she says you don't know
anything about my health or her health
already but nobody knows anything okay
so listen she has been fired she has
been fired um sap the company that she
used to work for put out a statement
after the woman was identified
saying quote the health and safety of
our employees and the communities in
which we live and work are of utmost
concern to us we are taking the matter
of an sap employee incident very
seriously and investigating the
situation
going on to say via twitter we have
reviewed the incident and can confirm
that the individual in question no
longer works for sap this is of course
the right decision for sap as a business
they made the decision that was best for
them and janine hoskovic now can go and
uh participate
in the marketplace of employment and of
ideas and there may well be a company
that will hire her because of this
unhinged coughing grant
or not and that would be the marketplace
of
ideas and employment that the right so
desperately claims to want so
that is one follow-up
that is a very very good thing and no
word on charges yet we did talk
yesterday about how under nebraska law
one a layman's interpretation of third
degree assault suggests that this could
be third degree assault that's one thing
in addition
in times of covid
one could
argue that federal terrorism charges
could actually be levied against folks
like this for deliberate coughing on
others i don't think we've seen it but
that was a legal opinion that was
floated a few months ago we looked at a
forbes article yesterday that explained
it as of yet
no charges that we know of against
janine hoskovec certainly being
judged in the court of public opinion as
the video has been viewed i mean the
original post was viewed more than four
million times but it's been replicated
and duped that's just on twitter
um between all of the reposts to youtube
and facebook i i assume at least 20
million people have seen this over the
last 48 hours so that's going on let's
go next to talking about texas we talked
about in the state of florida governor
ron desantis's approval rating
has collapsed as covid has beco as
florida rather has become a complete and
total coveted hellscape uh deliberately
delaying death numbers to always make it
look like deaths are on the decline just
a wacky wacky stuff going on in florida
and the good news is
uh it's bad that florida is a coveted
hellscape but it's good when a
politician's approval rating responds to
what is going on and it is it is just
and and justified that ron desantis
approval rating has declined greg
abbott's approval rating the governor of
texas has also now hit an all-time low
texas is also having its fair share of
covet problems article from truthout
outlining this texas governor greg
abbott's approval rating has dropped
over the past month as he has led
republicans in the state to pursue and
pass a number of restrictive and
discriminatory laws over the summer
polling done just before the abortion
ban in the state of texas took effect by
the texas politics project finds that
apple abbott's approval approval rating
went from a net even 44 approval and 44
disapproval in june to a net negative in
the group's most recent poll now 41 of
people polled approve of the gop
governor's job performance while 50
disapprove
abbott's approval rating dropped with
people across the partisan spectrum from
eight percent to six percent among
democrats not a big change there 77 to
73 percent among republicans and the
biggest drop 41 down to 30 percent
approval
among independents this is the lowest
approval for greg abbott since he took
office in 2015. the poll found a
majority believe texas is going in the
wrong direction only 35 percent believe
it's going in the right direction
part of the reason for the declining
approval and pessimism may be due to the
pandemic this is really an eye opener
for us the poll found texans generally
disapprove of abbott's handling of the
pandemic
that is also at its lowest level only 39
approval
the delta variant has surged across
texas
case rates are now flattening but the
state has some of the highest rates for
infections and deaths and a relatively
low vaccination rate only 48 percent
the mass mandate ban remember some
states
have put in place mass mandates other
states have put in place bans on mass
mandates that's texas that's unpopular
and importantly
the poll was conducted before the
abortion ban went into effect it is
quite plausible that the abortion ban
will also continue to send greg abbott's
approval rating further and further
into the toilet so this is all you know
my preference would be
that texas better handled covid that
texas didn't ban mask mandates that
texas didn't
pass oppressive restrictive abortion
bills that would be my preference but if
they are going to do those things then
i think it is better for the approval
rating of the governor that's doing it
to to sink and to go into the toilet uh
very often it feels as though
no matter what some of these politicians
do things just remain split among
partisan lines they mostly are remaining
split amongst partisan lines and what i
mean by that is almost no democrats
approve of abbot in uh texas and the
decline has only been a couple
percentage points
um most republicans approve of abbott
and the decline has been only a couple
percentage points but it's been the
independence where you see that 11
decline uh still it is good for the
approval polling to respond to the
disastrous things that greg abbott is
doing so that's texas
let's next talk about georgia
in georgia radical
republican congresswoman marjorie taylor
greene
is now being asked by the feds
to account for
3.5 million dollars in political
donations made to her
that she has not itemized this is very
very important
newsweek article says
the federal election commission the fec
has asked marjorie taylor greene for
more information
about three and a half million dollars
in contributions to her re-election
campaign
in two filings posted to the fec website
monday and surfaced on twitter by
georgia public broadcasting reporter
stephen fowler on tuesday the
congresswoman's husband perry green who
is also her treasurer
draining the swamp right was asked to
provide additional details about
donations the campaign received during
the first two quarters of 2021. look at
these numbers
between january and march the green
campaign received 2.5 million in
un-itemized donations from undisclosed
donors while the campaign received
another nearly million dollars in
un-itemized donations between april and
june the campaign reported a total of
more than four and a half million
dollars in donations during the same
period candidates are not look at this
candidates are not legally obliged to
itemize donations or disclose the
identity of donors for contributions
that total under two hundred dollars for
an election cycle for donations that do
need to be itemized campaigns must
supply details including name of the
donor address occupation employer and
the date of the donation the fec has
given the green campaign until october
12 to provide clarification about the
three and a half million to comply with
fec rules the campaign must either
provide information about the donors or
show the money came from small donors
only from at least 17 630 individuals
contributing no more than
199.99 each
um
it is conceivable mathematically that
this was only through small donations
but it is not particularly likely
so she pretended to be about draining
the swamp and yet she is the swamp
unitimized donations husband is campaign
treasurer anybody sick of hearing about
these stories and then nothing ever
actually ends up happening like
everything these people do
everything these people
do yes
is a grift
i'm still wondering how did she get away
with declaring two homestead exemptions
at the same time on her taxes do you
even remember that story that was
was it six months ago was it 12 months
ago you're only allowed to have one
homestead
exemption or declaration
marjorie taylor green had two
and we discovered that it was being
investigated i've heard nothing since
what's going on with that could this be
as simple as marjorie taylor green just
as using her campaign donations as a
personal slush fund and used it for
personal expenses could it be that
simple
hopefully we'll find out more and she
has until october 12th to disclose the
oranges or the origins per your
preference
and usage
of those donations we will try to follow
it unfortunately too often the story
goes nowhere and we never hear about it
again uh we'll be covering these stories
as well as updates to other stories from
earlier this week
on the david pakman show instagram make
sure you're following us there at david
pakman show and follow me at
david.pacman
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpackman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount joinpakman.com
it's great to welcome to the program
today henry giroux who is the chaired
professor of scholarship in the public
interest at mcmaster university his most
recent book is race politics and
pandemic pedagogy published this year by
bloomsbury it's so great to have you on
i appreciate your time today
i'm delighted to be here
so you know there there's been many
political analyses made of this
authoritarian slide that we've seen that
we could say led up to the election of
donald trump in 2016 but then also was
further fomented by the election of
donald trump in 2016. i'm interested uh
to hear from you
more your thoughts on the cultural
aspect of this and how far back you
think the the kind of catalysts for this
slide go and how we should sort of be
conceiving of it
i mean i i think we've seen uh extra
political and
cultural extremism in the in the united
states it has a long history
uh i mean we've seen it with the
mccarthy period we saw with the red
scare and then of course there's the
legacy of colonization i mean there's
the
wiping out of indigenous populations
there's jim crow there's slavery and i
think that one of the things that this
country has failed to confront is not
only that legacy but how it tends to
reappear in different forms in different
historical moments and i think that
where i see an enormous turning point in
the united states is in the 1970s
all of a sudden it seems to me there's
there's a counter-revolution emerging
against the 60s against the
democratization of the social order
against the attempt to in in some way
eliminate massive inequalities and
wealth and power and with reagan
something happens and what happens is
there's an enormous shift in cultural
values and that shift moves away from
supporting the public good to basically
in many ways destroying it and claiming
that the market now should be the
template not simply for judging the
economy or managing the economy but for
all of social life this has an
enormously destructive
uh consequence it seems to me in the
united states and it begins to give rise
to far right wing movements
who for the most part hate the public
good hate the common good and all of a
sudden find themselves on the side of
reproducing echoes of history
that are pretty dangerous whether we're
talking about right-wing extremism
racial purity misogyny militarism
ultra-nationalism i mean all these
forces begin to come into
become very visible and come to the
surface in light of the increasing
misery that i call neoliberalism or
gangster capitalism
produces as a result of the 1980s when i
when i spoke to noam chomsky a couple of
months ago the political points that he
thought were relevant in that period
you're talking about
include as a reaction to the civil
rights movement
the establish the establishment of the
war on drugs for example
the fight against roe v wade and that
some of these points led to what the
republican party became in the early 90s
under newt gingrich and then we can sort
of like follow the political line
culturally though what was it about
those things that were happening prior
to during and after the 70s that kind of
changed this american right wing i mean
what you begin to see culturally a
couple of things ideologically you see
a an
ideology of self-interest
reproduced in many ways in celebrity
culture and consumerism
citizenship takes on a very different
form culturally after the 1980s all of a
sudden the obligations of citizenship
citizenship have to do with consumerism
the mall becomes the temple of of the
state so to speak but you also see
something else you see a rise in what i
call the punishing state and a decline
of the social state and with that comes
a number of cultural apparatuses that
begin to reinforce what i call the most
insidious
cultural aspect of neoliberalism or
gangster capitalism and that is the
individualization of problems
everything becomes privatized all
problems are a matter of individual
responsibility and what that means
culturally is it becomes increasingly
difficult for people to translate
private troubles into larger systemic
considerations so the social begins to
collapse now what happens as a result of
that culturally what happens is you have
the war on drugs you have of course
clinton's uh war on the welfare state
you you have the southern strategy i
mean all of things all of these things
combine a question of racial purity and
what i call white supremacy with the
logic of capitalism somebody has to be
blamed
and who has to be blamed are immigrants
or blacks
or young people you know all those
groups that are relatively powerless in
the face of this overwhelmingly
political and cultural apparatus now
david there's something else
and i think the other side of this is
what we have to understand is that
education takes a radical turn in the
1980s it increasingly becomes privatized
commodified
undermined defunded and all of a sudden
we're not talking about educating people
to be critical engaged citizens anymore
we're talking about them we're talking
about teachers to teach with the test
yep just runs through a whole range of
presidents i mean the republican and the
democratic parties both share a notion
of education as anti-intellectual
destroys the civic imagination uh
imposes what i call a pedagogy of
repression and basically produce and
increases an anti-intellectualism that
is in the schools and in the larger
cultural apparatuses second
second point don't confuse schooling
with education
legit schooling is an institution that
we know of public hire but education
takes place in other spheres
the the the new social media the digital
media the rise of what i call an
oracular image-based culture and these
are largely controlled by the right and
so you have this tsunami of
anti-intellectualism right-wing nonsense
lies misinformation conspiracy theories
emerging since the 1970s and you find
their endpoint in trump
i want to get back to the education
piece because i have so many notes about
it one small thing that i was thinking
of in your your cultural idea of the
kind of individualization of problems
is this related to the gun issue in the
united states in this specific sense
that unlike in many other countries
too many people in the u.s see guns as a
way to solve problems
that are that are really systemic
problems but they say i will solve
individually this problem with a firearm
i think it's a brilliant analysis and i
think it's right on target i i think
that basically when you individualize
problems you say that people have to
take are both responsible for those
problems individually and have the right
to engage them in ways that suggest that
the government is the enemy of freedom
rather than something that could be
useful in dealing with these issues the
the other side of this is that when you
individualize problems in this way
you can't address them systemically so
you begin to increasingly criminalize
social problems
so you know if youth for instance acting
out in schools you know the principal
doesn't come down and say hey come on
let's talk you call the police and all
of a sudden you have little
five-year-olds in handcuffs in
kindergarten uh so it seems to me with
this increasing criminalization of
social problems you have a notion of
freedom emerging that is completely
removed from this any notion of social
responsibility right a notion of freedom
that simply says i can do what i want
self-interest is all that matters uh all
problems are individualized this is what
i call the individualization of the
social and in the social sphere and the
social contract and the social good
and the public good david begin to
collapse
we lose those sites where people can
understand the interconnections that
make a democracy possible couple that
with an education and schooling system
that basically produces new forms of
civic illiteracy and you don't have a
democracy anymore because you can't have
a democracy without informed citizens
so on education i frequently will get
calls from viewers
i mean listen talking about
individualizing things i will get calls
from viewers who say
my cousin my uncle whoever
they've fallen for false beliefs about
vaccines
they've fallen for false beliefs about
it doesn't matter what but they're not
thinking they've just they've fallen for
it how do i talk them out of it and i
struggle to say anything other than you
know at the individual level it can take
weeks or months of really getting
someone to re-examine their beliefs
that's like a retail strategy it's not a
wholesale strategy my instinct is
it's too late and and really if people
learned critical thinking and media
literacy and epistemology in middle
school we prevent this from even
happening in the first place to some
degree not with everybody but maybe we
give people the tools to not fall into
this in the first place is that a fair
critique of
of at least a piece of what's wrong with
the educational or schooling system as
you call it today
no i think it's an important piece i
mean it's foundational and that the way
we educate people says something about
the kind of agents we produce and the
kind of future we want
and it seems to me education in
schooling in that sense is very long
term i think the other side of this is
that you know how do we talk about
taking control of these cultural
apparatuses that basically are
disimagination machines i mean we're not
just talking about uh how do you say it
the ability to get people to think
critically or rationally or to be able
to engage other positions that's
important but we're also talking about
larger systemic apparatuses that need to
be challenged by people like us like in
social movements and reproduced in ways
that give people the opportunity to be
able to recognize that the most
fundamental questions are not whether
they're falling for lies but what kind
of future do they want for their
children do they want health care that's
free do they want to be in debt
for the rest of their lives critical
consciousness matters but it has to
translate ideas have to translate and be
wedded to power and it seems to be when
we remove the question of power from the
question of insight we fall into a trap
that we unconsciously reproduce that we
may want to stay away from and that is
to say well just talk to each other no
i'm sorry it's not about just talking
about each other it's about changing the
very institutions that have put us there
in the first place and that's not just
the burden of people who are confused
that's that's a political obligation
that we all have to engage in with those
people hopefully so in that sense i mean
when when you hear these very
superficial narratives of part of the
problem is
left and right don't engage anymore or
the the dialogue has coarsened this type
of stuff
is does that not really strike you as
particularly important that's a
diversion i find that as a political
diversion because it doesn't deal with
fundamental questions like look what's
the result of massive inequality in the
united states and where does it come
from right what is it what does it mean
when some people are trading medicine
for for
you know for food stamps you know what
does it mean when schools are collapsing
you know that's not a matter of whether
the right and left can talk to each
other that's a matter of how do we talk
about democracy as a country if we're
going to take democracy seriously and
what are the forces that are undermining
it these are very different kinds of
questions what does it mean to live in a
country where economic activity is
removed from social cost what's the
consequence of that and how does it bear
down on our lives the the last thing is
that we have to be able
shame is a terrible pedagogical tool
i think shaming people does nothing but
just reinforce the worst divisions and i
think the real question here for all of
us is how do we begin to use a language
in which people can recognize themselves
in which we can shift consciousness in
ways in which people can say yeah that's
that makes sense to me without putting
their identities on trial we need a
language that's rigorous accessible in
order to make something meaningful to
make it critical to make it
transformative can you give an example
of that in terms of
on any issue could you give an example
of the wrong way that the language is
being used and then how it could be
improved i i mean i i think in talking
to people that for instance are dealing
with schools people will often say
schools are failing it's terrible i
think we should home school and one of
the questions i always raise is that if
school is so crucial do you think school
is crucial to to democracy to your life
for your children yes then why is it
being defunded
schools aren't failing they've they've
been defunded i mean the problem is not
that schools are failing the problem is
that they actually serve a very
important purpose in society and we have
to ask ourselves why do people want to
destroy them and why do some people have
access and you don't what can we do to
make schools matter in your community
how would we do that together how would
we speak to that how would we make
schools more richer what resources do we
need what policies what does it mean to
get on a school board can we do that in
order to change your curriculum so that
you have for instance free meals for
your kid in the morning kid is starving
can't learn sorry you know right
teachers who have 47 kids in a class
can't learn so i think when we start to
deal with particulars
and make them resonate with the very
conditions that people can recognize in
their lives we make something meaningful
to make it blah blah i'll give you one
last example people often say to me why
don't you come to the united states come
back and i said well would you get
national health care
and i said what do you mean i say look
i've had two knee surgeries i didn't
have to pay to pay i don't pay a pen a
cent
you know my drugs are basically free
i can walk into a corner or a doctor's
office a drop-in center and get free
medical care and they don't believe this
stuff
and you know when i say you know most
debt in the united states is now due to
medical expenses right
i mean you know and i know just recently
one hospital i think in tennessee
charged somebody six thousand seven
hundred fifty dollars for three tests
for coronavirus you know this this sort
of thing has to be talked about and
illustrated and then in some way
connected to people's lives in terms of
um the language that we're seeing to
sort of shift back a little bit to our
to the earlier part of the conversation
uh federico finkelstein from the new
school regularly a fellow argentinian i
i might add um he uh has written a lot
about the analogous language between you
know past authoritarians and dictators
and the kind of modern language of trump
etc
two-part question one to what degree do
you see the language as analogous and
two
are these politically uh astute
comparisons to be making from a
practical perspective even if they are
true
i think they're absolutely practical and
i know his work and i know him and i and
i think that if we can't learn from the
past as the old saying goes we're more
than doomed to to repeat it we might as
we might find ourselves in places that
we never could imagine could happen we
might find ourselves faced with the
unthinkable and i think that when we
talk about ultra nationalism we talk
about militarism i mean we talk about
for instance the 1930s and the 40s one
of the things that we have to make clear
is simply because
fashion what i call fascist politics
emerges but doesn't present itself in an
exact replica does not mean it doesn't
exist it means that it's always in
remission but tends to emerge in
different forms and i think that what we
have to look at are the signals we have
to look at the similarities and
certainly he's absolutely right as is
timothy schneider jason stanley and a
number of others who were saying hey
look look at this language lies how
central with the question of lies in for
instance in the nazi regime racial
purity racial cleansing what does that
tell us where did that go in the 1930s
and 40s the appeal to militarism hyper
masculinity the attack on women's bodies
the attack on others the friend enemy
distinction
uh the the the ongoing attempt to
demonize people and to claim that the
public's fear is only for white people
my god i mean if that doesn't conjure up
an image of the past and echoes of the
past that we should take seriously then
they aren't then if you believe if you
don't believe in that analysis you're
going to have to end up in a cell
somewhere before you actually realize
right that fascist politics is here
alive well and throbbing think about the
january 6th
attack
i mean even roberto paxton who first was
a great historian of fascism who said no
trump is not a fascist has come out
recently and said i was wrong
i'm sorry the line has been crossed we
are basically now in a fascist culture
and fascist politics is on the rise of
the united states and represents a very
dangerous moment
uh the latest book from henry giroux is
race politics and pandemic pedagogy
published by bloomsbury we've been
speaking with henry drew chaired
professor for scholarship in the public
interest at mcmaster university it's
been so great having you on i can't tell
you how much i appreciate your time
today
oh thank you david it's a pleasure
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com david pakman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos the daily bonus show
the commercial free daily show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies
mugs and t-shirts you can support the
show for as little as two dollars a
month check it out at patreon.com
davidpakmanshow all right let's jump
into a sort of very strange interview
that fox news host greg gutfeld did on
uh
on his show i i i don't know if this is
still a comedy show or not it has a
laugh track it sounds like it's a very
strange show
now i've exchanged some messages with
greg gutfeld in the past and sometimes
when we talk about things he does and
point out how ridiculous and humiliating
they are he'll tweet and say you know
this wasn't good or something like that
so i i understand gutfeld may see this
and he may not like it uh what was
notable about this interview that he had
is that it was with the former president
donald trump often in
interviews with trump trump's the only
guy who's humiliated um but in this
interview it's both trump and gutfeld
this is
this is maybe
this would make maria bartoromo blush
it's so
fawning and brown-nosing of donald trump
the interview opens with gutfeld
basically saying he loves trump
and his pr even like his prior critiques
of things trump said were maybe like not
fair it's very strange check this out
right and then you started and now i
think i don't know if it's love but it's
getting close and we like it it's not i
wouldn't say it's love but i would say
it's admiration
and also admitting that i was wrong
because i was focusing on words and not
deeds and now we're at a time where okay
there are no more mean tweets and we
have a really nice president because
he's been banned from twitter and the
country is in the crapper so who would
you rather have well i don't know that
he's a nice president
i'm
what is the laughing like
is this
is there a studio audience that's
reacting is it a laugh track is this a
comedy show is it a news show it's all
very weird it's not working as either
quite frankly
but i can tell you the country has never
been more unsafe we have people pouring
in through our southern border which
everyone's talking about that's not true
forgetting about right now because of
the travesty of afghanistan and if you
look at the people coming in by like you
could gut felt instead of saying wright
could so easily disable that and defuse
it and say oh
how have the numbers changed of people
coming in and how have deportation
numbers changed and you know give us
that trump would say well i don't know
but it's just it's really bad just go
just look just look hundreds by the
thousands and these are not the people
necessarily that wanted the protection
right these are people so are they
terrorists how many terrorists are
coming in and they were aggressive very
aggressive at the plane and they pushed
gutfeld is saying right and yes to every
single thing trump says after talking
about how great trump is
gutfeld then asks trump
what would you say to my wife to
convince her to get vaccinated
apparently
gutfeld's wife isn't vaccinated and
trump goes well i recommend it but if
she doesn't want to she shouldn't like
he he still has to be careful because if
he really says like just get vaccinated
his audience will go nuts because you
had covid and i my wife you met my wife
it was like six years ago uh in
mar-a-lago she's still not gotten
vaccinated and i keep talking to her to
get her to get vaccinated and she hasn't
what would you say to her well first of
all say why is she not doing it does she
have some kind of religious things no
skeptical she skeptical doesn't trust i
think there was a laugh that like there
was laughing when trump asked why
th
if someone's using a laugh track it's
being used at very strange times russian
yes she's scripted that's the end of
that exactly you can't argue with the
russian no you're me very smart yeah
yeah very hard-headed yes i think i know
your wife a little bit right yes trump
20 seconds ago trump seemed not to
remember meeting her but now trump is
talking about how well he knows
gutfeld's wife could
is this considered a news interview and
uh let her do what she wants to do i got
vaccinated and i feel very good i think
we saved millions and millions of people
worldwide you know in 1917 they say it's
1918. almost 100 million approximately
100 million people died yeah i think we
could have been into that situation
because it was very bad
and now if you vaccinated the other
thing it shows that if you do get sick
you don't get sick like they were before
meaning you don't die exactly trump's
right about all this by the way so
i would recommend but i also say that
let her have her freedoms you know the
word freedom right yeah exactly and with
you she needs freedom
she needs a lot of freedom from me i
found out gutfeld the the premise was
how can i convince my wife to get
vaccinated but as soon as trump says her
freedom not to get vaccinated is
important gut felt says yeah exactly
there there's nothing
trump said during this interview where
gutfeld wasn't like well
hold on a second um here then the
questioning gets really tough gutfeld
asks trump how hard is it to be
president from one to ten
was it a difficult job
question i bet no one's ever asked you
this i think i might know the answer
well
a five-year-old would ask this
donald it
is it hard to be the pres that this is
what a little kid would ask so it's it's
not nobody is no no reporter a
journalist would ask such a dumb
question
how hard is it
being prep being president from a scale
to one to ten
well i had now
hear the laughing makes sense right the
the question is so stupid that i
actually think there was not enough
laughing here
two forms of presidency number one i had
to run the country work on the world and
do things and the other thing i had to
survive yeah the survival was much
tougher
um listen he was busy not only being
president but trying to keep up with
golfing
watching tv and fending off sexual
assault lawsuits really tough stuff and
then here's just the last clip
in this one trump suggests that taliban
leaders when he speaks speaks to them on
the phone
that they grunt now what's funny is
supposedly
biden would be bad for dealing with the
taliban here trump talks about when he
would deal with the taliban but it's all
about calling them abdul and saying they
grunt oh it is christmas it's christmas
they're still celebrating yes okay so i
told you about abdul he's tough and when
i first spoke to him by phone
i said
nice to speak to you by phone abdul and
he goes
you know they're ferocious people
you know like you go to broadway shows
they fight they like to fight they've
been fighting for about a thousand years
however
what a humiliating interview and then
now i'm gonna now drop in the cherry on
top this is like nothing i've ever seen
um gutfeld says yes to everything he
opens the interview by saying how great
trump is
he asks questions like how hard was it
to be president from one to ten
he says right to everything trump says
and then this guy named uh titus or
tyrus i ty
tyrus i think it is who has a wrestling
belt he's i guess a panelist on this
program he says you know what was great
about this interview greg gutfeld you
didn't kiss trump's ass
tyrus did you watch the interview it's
beyond parody
take a look i normally would never do
this man but wow man that was
that was a written one
no but it was
it was a conversation and you didn't
change
no
people when they interview presidents
change you didn't kiss his ass
what
what did you see the interview yeah and
i applaud you and you got a great you
had a conversation you even told him i
didn't like because i used to hear him
going this guy this guy here
and that was that was a great
conversation it is it is truly beyond
parody and it is just stunning that this
uh i mean what
that interview would have made maria
bartoromo blush
that's how much of a of a sycophant
brown-nosing interview it was uh i
i hope gutfeld feels humiliated because
he should it was a humiliating interview
okay i i do want to get to something a
little more substantive we continue to
see this debate over statues and
monuments and statues are getting pulled
down when they are
sometimes confederate statues or
whatever the case may be and we have
another example of that in virginia in
richmond virginia
a robert e lee statue has been removed
robert e lee a big confederate general
essentially a traitor it was robert e
lee was a guy
fighting against the union aka the
united states at the time
for the right to continue owning slaves
he was a pro-slavery trader to the
united states is the way that i would
put it
robert e lee statue was taken down in
richmond virginia and donald trump put
out a statement saying that the statue
was magnificent and robert e lee was a
genius
what i mean it it's beyond words it's
beyond words let's take a look at the
statement this put out through the save
america pack of president donald j trump
trump says
just watched as a massive crane took
down the magnificent and very famous
statue of robert e lee on his horse in
richmond virginia it has long been
recognized it's waxing poetic about a
confederate statue it has long been
recognized as a beautiful piece of
bronze sculpture to add insult to injury
those who support this taking now plan
to cut it into three pieces and throw
this work of art into storage prior to
its complete desecration
robert e lee is considered by many
generals to be the greatest strategist
of them all now greatest strategist this
is like saying
nazi the german army's nazi strategist
hermann goring was really a good
strategist that doesn't mean we have a
statue for the guy okay um robert e lee
is considered by many generals to be the
greatest strategist of them all
president lincoln wanted him to command
the north in which case the war would
have been over in one day
robert e lee instead chose the other
side because of his great love of
virginia
and except for gettysburg would have won
the war he should be remembered as
perhaps the greatest unifying force
after the war was over arden in his
resolve to bring the north and south
together through many means of
reconciliation and imploring his
soldiers to do their duty in becoming
good citizens of this country
um
our culture is being destroyed in our
history and heritage both good and bad
are being extinguished by the radical
left and we can't let that happen if
only we had robert e lee to command our
troops in afghanistan that disaster
would have ended in a complete and total
victory many years ago
what an embarrassment we are suffering
because we don't have the genius
of a robert e lee
this is what the former president of the
united states
has been relegated to
praising
pro-slavery confederate generals
as
geniuses and bemoaning the removal of a
statue now i've said before
i actually don't pay too much attention
to this statue stuff in that i i don't
find it particularly substantive now if
you come to me and you say david sir
do you would you remove the statue yeah
of course i would remove it
or would you rename the middle school
away from being named after a
confederate general yeah absolutely
absolutely
but for me it's not a big substantive
focus is the point that i'm trying to
make but the bemoaning it as the
greatest loss
also strikes me as completely unhinged
deranged and wacky so there is trump
saying this man was a genius this
pro-slavery general who fought for uh uh
who fought for the confederacy
is a genius and the statue is
magnificent and it should remain that's
just horrifying stuff all right we have
a voicemail number and that number is
2192 david p here's a great voicemail
because it points out the impossibility
the it points out the conflict between
different biden conspiracy theories on
the one hand the idea that biden is just
a puppet and someone else is really
running the show and on the other hand
the idea that biden is ruining
everything and is responsible for
everything bad that's going on take a
listen to this
hey david i'm curious about something i
thought maybe you could uh answer for me
yeah
why is it that
biden
is a puppet
kamala harris is running the country
kamala
he's a old man who just babbles and
doesn't even know what room he's in
yet
it's completely his fault every time
something yes goes wrong yeah no this is
great because
if someone else is actually the biden
puppet master
we we should be blaming them whenever
something goes wrong right but biden is
simultaneously a disastrous president
making disastrous decisions who deserves
singular blame for everything that goes
bad
and also
not actually in charge of anything and
other people are controlling it it's
just yet another one it's sort of like
uh
this is the
greatest vaccine ever developed by trump
which we actually aren't going to go and
accept because the virus isn't that
serious and we don't really need
vaccines well then in what sense is it
really a major accomplishment for trump
if it's a vaccine we don't need for
something that's not serious anyway
these people are pathetic on the bonus
show today we will talk about joe
manchin's latest list of demands and
whether anybody should listen to them we
will talk about a three million dollar
deal that's been reached in the case of
the rough arrest of a woman with
dementia and lastly amazon is going to
open some cashier-less whole food stores
next year
there's also amazon go stores and this
could be a real paradigm shift in terms
of
the way grocery stores are organized and
i have some specific thoughts i'll share
with you all of that on today's bonus
show
get instant access by signing up at
jointman.com and i will see you then
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors
blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an entire
non-fiction book in just 15 minutes you
can try it for free and get 25 off a
subscription by going to blinkist.com
david pakman